alors ton père était officier de marine
ils portent chance qu'il était
catholique ont quitté cathay les épées
étoiles
moi je ne suis pas pratiquant mais je
suis catholique je suis moyen sais même
pas ce que c'est que la religion
catholique et la compréhension que
connaît la confession jeu que j'ai connu
ouais tu verrais de confesser avec moi
dans un coin sombre
bah oui mais là je crois qu'ils les
caméras non non non bon alors ça va ça
va la tuer avec moi ok yves lecoq de la
messieurs
les
ce que tu crois en dieu we died de prier
les fois où il ya la manière d'ailleurs
ça peut être dans une église mais c'est
peut être ça peut être n'importe où à
mon avis il faut que cette terre est
décédé quand le prier de ne pas remonter
si loin que ça j'ai dû prier j'ai pas
c'était quoi ça fait pour enrayer le
fléau de certaines personnes qui
s'abattent sur certaines personnes la
maladie j'en connais tu es un ami que
les malades et de prier pour lui j'ai
une amie qui sortent de deux ce qui est
soi disant maladie crainte je pense que
c'est par un essai de tribus dont elle
est aussi de prier pour des amis qui ne
sont pas sortis pour longtemps mais ça
n'empêche pas réessayer
est ce que tu pourrais pas que
aujourd'hui dans ta carrière tu n'es pas
encore complètement débloquer certains
ne veux pas te montrer tels que tu es
aux gens et finalement c'est un blocage
qui est bloquée je vais quitter nuit ce
plan professionnel j'ai citron prendre
cinq fois son jeu
j'ai une période de livres qui étaient
dans cas dans l'adolescence où l'âge
était spontanée après s'agit de bloquer
différents avatars de ma vie et
c'est vrai que je joue j'ai l'impression
d'en sortir un peu je pense que c'est
bénéfique évidemment pas tricher avec
soi même certainement la meilleure
solution
quand on part nathalie de privée par
exemple qui est lui toujours les
questions bon
non parce que seule la vie privée par
pas seulement comme son nom l'indiqué
elle est personnelle jem veut garder
s'ils j'ai pas envie de la rue en me
disent alors comment ça va à côté cumul
terrain vous avez dit ceci ou cela est
ce que je peux faire quelque chose pour
vous ça ne regarde que moi tu crois que
tu te faut grèce c'est quand même qu'un
jour je serai complètement libérés ou
que tu vas rester bloqué comme ça non
j'espère me libérer les rangs sur un dix
ans parce que je crois que je vais vivre
vieux l'a prêté d'après tmz info ou
intox
c'est ce qu'on souhaite donc merci